like your fingerprints are everywhere
like you just told me a story about your
first tape with Gucci
were you removed Nicki Minaj's verse
because she wasn't popping yet
God why are we talking about this
Nikki I apologize so what happened
um me and Gucci's first actual gangster
girls we actually did one with Yo Gotti
first it was called definition of a g
that was the first tape me and uh Gucci
had did together it was collaboration
Gotti Gucci and me the first official
Gucci Man gangster girls was called the
movie
and when he brought it to me the first
song that was for the tape the first
voice you heard on the S on the tape was
Nicki Minaj obviously this is a uh early
Nicki Minaj and disrespectfully you know
I felt like
we can't have a gangster girls with me
and Gucci and the first voice you hear
not be Gucci so I removed her
um perverse her verse from that song I
feel terrible to this day did she know
it was your decision
um
I don't know she she may know now but in
defense I will say that
I made sure out of everyone that Nicki
Minaj was on dedication three because
Nicki Minaj was about to get left off of
dedication three she was calling me
directly say dram please don't let the
tape come out without me on there and I
said I got you so Nicki Minaj is on
dedication three directly because I made
sure she was on there so so you got it
came back I'm trying to make it up I'm
trying to you know did anyone ever hear
the Nikki verse that you remember if you
ever use it anywhere else did that I
don't I really don't know I don't know
whatever came from that we'd have to
probably ask Gucci do you still have
like your OG email access I wish I had a
gangster girls.com Gmail that was
probably just some [__] in there
so crazy I used to get these [__]
Beats
from this like random email from like it
was like boy idea or something like I
was like who is this boy idea sending me
all these beats like in like 0506 you
should flood my email because you know
how to pronounce the name it's a weird
name and now looking back why wasn't it
yeah I've told him that I've definitely
we've talked about that like [__] was
crazy yeah cause I just think about like
even the last two or three years the
research like if you think about it we
went through this weird cycle where the
blogs would drop the no DJ version of
mixtapes as well as the DJ versions of
mixtapes and I remember you having an
issue with that and
um I felt used yeah because they would
use the gangster girl's brand yeah to
like launch it and then like a week
later and they would drop like a no DJ
version without your [__] on it yeah
like what the [__] but now we like kind
of like came back around now everybody
is getting the gangster grills and
they're dropping them on dsps like I
mean shots Perico you guys just dropped
that one
there was a day recently where I feel
like you had three tapes come out in one
day and one day I dropped gz snowfall
Snoop and NBA young boy that was crazy
like I was like on the that was like
right after I won DJ of the year or two
with the hip-hop Awards
I was like oh yeah I'm coming from
coming for the next year's award how
like how much do you feel like because
if people don't know you're also uh you
like and Don have cultivated a label
called generation now that has two of
the biggest superstars in hip-hop period
at the moment Jack Harlow and little Uzi
that's
um so you've obviously been
busy yeah you've been put you've also
put out records you've been you've been
listen it's like you never went anywhere
but do you feel like the Tyler album
sparked the gangster grills Resurgence
thousand percent
thousand percent you gotta gotta tip
your head off to you know I saw someone
say like of all people who would have
thought Tyler the Creator of people have
called a weirdo for
thus long would bring gangster girls
back to life like yeah I mean one just
the ingenious idea of him
of the the concept of him making his
album against the girls and utilizing me
the way it did and two obviously us
winning a Grammy like come on you can't
you can't deny
like Tyler had a lot to do with it and I
still think that that like
you know just even recently I saw like
Benny and Westside Gunn uh make some
references like yo we got drama out of
his executive bag like you know even
before Tyler I had I had he did the BSF
[__] I did BSF [__] I did some [__] on
guns project so you know there there
were some other projects you know out
there so I think like
um there you know clearly like as a
brand gangster girls was still strong
but I think you know the the the
response and just what Tyler's album did
like really that's we have a lot to
thank for that for sure like or even the
Jeezy snowfall like that was in the
works by the way the best Jeezy album in
I don't know what are we think in 10
years sometime it's been it's been a
while I was like yeah we were in New
York riding around listening to that
[__] when it came out I was like God
damn Jizzy back on his [__] yeah and uh
how'd that feel